this is uh I don't even I just want to
talk about it it's like not the most
important or political thing but
apparently right before the show we saw
this tweet from um
Rick and Morty Adult Swim retweeted they
said Adult Swim has ended its
association with Justin Roiland Rick and
Morty will continue the talented and
dedicated crew are hard at work on
season seven now I know a lot of people
don't care about Rick and Morty or
whatever it's a show you might like it
or not but apparently this is they're
canceling the guy who does the voices of
the two main characters on the show but
keeping the show because he got accused
of domestic abuse is that what it is
yeah domestic abuse and then what's
false imprisonment yeah what tell me
what happened what is this story I don't
know everything exactly but apparently
he had like a domestic abuse a domestic
uh disturbance and then they call it and
then he was uh I think his girlfriend at
the time or girl that was involved in a
situation called the police and he was
like keeping her inside of a bathroom
and then he got charged with both
domestic abuse and he also got charged
with uh let's see like uh I think false
imprisonment this article says one
failing count of domestic battery with
corporal injury and one felony count of
false Improvement by Menace violence
fraud and or deceit notice but these are
charges these aren't even this happened
on January 19th 2020. right so this is
the important thing there's a couple
reasons why I think this is interesting
one how do you cancel the like the
voice of the guy but keep the show but
he this is a guy who's being charged he
has not been convicted
you know how do you how do you handle
something like that and this happened 20
or in 2020 two years ago three three
years ago three years ago January did he
just get Char he just recently got
charged and and this is yeah it looks
like the criminal complaint uh so
reaching the media last week so I don't
know if that means that the woman who's
unidentified she's being identified as
Jane Doe came forward later and they've
just been compiling it or what he
resigned from his game squanch games
yeah when like January 16th right there
so he knew this was coming so obviously
this has been under investigation for a
little bit yeah that's crazy this is how
it usually always goes though right with
uh like it you usually don't wait until
conviction to remove someone from their
position like you know police
departments put people on leave when
they're you know investigating I
remember like with Chris Hardwick during
like the me too stuff that was wrong
though yeah I agree but at the same time
like that's usually how it goes is they
that's they don't wait until like a
conviction or anything like that that's
kind of what I'm what I'm thinking about
this story I mean aside from the fact
that it's very weird they're going to be
like what are they gonna do replace the
voices and you're going to get like a
weird Rick and Morty they don't sound
the same and it's gonna be a weird show
like he does the jokes here's what makes
it funny but yeah we went through this
with me too when it was hard work he was
falsely accused they took him off the
show and then finally they're like oops
then you had Aziz Ansari who was accused
of having a bad date yeah that was
amazing she was like I had a bad date
and then everyone was trying to cancel
this guy and it's like now Justin
Roiland look maybe he did it if he did
then he should he should get you know
yeah I feel like it's gonna be hard
until they release some more information
so they're saying like body cams from
the police all the details are being
withheld from the public uh pending a
protective order he also there's a
protective order in place against like
for for the victim so he's not allowed
to come within 100 feet of this person
through October 2023. so it seems like
there's obviously been some steps taken
in between but you're totally right like
it's hard to know what exactly is
happening and of course anyone is
Presumed Innocent the complaint alleges
that he did willfully and unlawfully
inflict corporal injury resulting in a
traumatic condition Upon A Jane Doe who
was in a dating relationship they said
that he did unlawfully violate the
personal Liberty of Jane Doe by violence
Menace fraud and deceit yeah what does
that mean he pleaded not guilty in 2020.
so he was charged a long time ago yeah
yeah yeah this is crazy about it he was
released in August of 2020 and his
statement they said it's hard to
overstate how inaccurate the recent
media coverage in the situation has been
to be clear not only is just an innocent
but we also have every expectation that
this matter is on a course to be
dismissed once the DA's office has
completed its methodical review of The
Evidence we look forward to clearing
Justin's name and helping him move
forward as swiftly as possible so what
do you think false false accusation well
I mean if he's already if they if
they're looking for him to be exonerated
that's what they said right they expect
to they expect this missile just ought
to be dismissed well I mean it's a bold
statement yeah dismissals like just you
know it's all not a real not a real
thing and he's already lost his job
because of it wow man I mean okay there
are one of the most popular shows that
adult swims produce in the past at least
10 years one of the most populations
IMDb top 100 or whatever yeah of all
time ever yeah wow
I mean the the show's over
they're not going to get someone that's
going to be he's the brains behind it
they're not going to be able to I mean
it's like trying to do South Park
without without trying Matt Stone and
Trey yeah yeah I mean or does it just
like
you know we have a couple missed seasons
and then eventually they bring it back
with sort of a semi-change title I don't
know there are some states where like
you can be charged with kidnapping like
if if surgery is right like he locked
his girlfriend in the bathroom I was
like you're not allowed to leave they're
they're having some obviously bad
argument right like they can some states
will say like you're violating her
um
her I forgot which one it is but it's
one of her uh constitutional rights like
her right to free movement you're you're
restricting her so
it may not be like he's a crazy psycho
but this obviously could have been a
very bad dynastic situation and that to
me would come to like if it goes to
court if it goes trial if he gets
exonerated like there's a chance that
Adults Swim could like hold back for a
couple years and then be like okay we'll
release like a movie back up we can't
function in society if someone can
accuse you of something and then before
anything's been proven they just say
like okay you're removed from your job
and we're destroying this portion of the
economy that was what I don't mean like
the entirety of the global economy I'm
saying like this element of economic
activity everyone's job at Rick and
Morty it's not just one guy yeah
everybody loses their job now because of
the accusation now again if he if it's a
legitimate accusation then he then so be
it dude gets locked up but the fact that
it's not proven yet he's denying it
they're saying outright it will be
dismissed well okay that needs to be
adjudicated we need to go through that
with that evidence a jury whatever yeah
but the fact that they would be like
nope the punishment has been handed down
yeah we're is it it's it's reminiscent
of the meat to BS that was the problem
with me too was that well we mentioned a
disease and sorry like that was kind of
like the last the last time that I heard
a lot of noise about it because people
realized that
a lot of the people that had stuff that
was legitimate that were actually going
to come forward had come forward like
all the people that had that that were
inspired by me too like they if they had
the courage to come forward they did it
in the beginning if they if they were
legitimately uh you know
assaulted or whatever and they didn't
come out in the beginning it wasn't
likely they were going to come out after
six months or whatever and so the people
that were coming out in the later you
know the later days of of of me too
tended to be the people that were like
complaining about in season sorry who
had a bad day and there was uh other
people but like that's the thing it was
hilarious it's a bad date no my favorite
response to that was like someone being
like where are that girl's friends being
like why are why are you putting
yourself in the scenario like you don't
have to do this like it was such a weird
story all around and I think it like it
took like me too is so complicated and
of course people who are truly me too
it's complicated he is these and sorry
stories
someone would be like I am also a part
of you know potentially like you know
people who are really abused like that
tells you how delusional this can get
like people want to be recognized as
victims and think they have something to
gain in this case like I totally with
him it's crazy that there is like a
whole studio of people who are basically
out of a job because of this and I
feel like the only way for anyone to
know is for it to go to trial which
those articles last forever I don't
think that it doesn't matter if it goes
to trial I think that the people that
have already decided that he's guilty
they're gonna all they're always going
to believe that's exactly right like
it's all gonna hang on so but like for
my position is like if he gets like I
was on pop culture once and we were
talking about Mike Tyson Mike Tyson's
been convicted of rape and someone was
like I can't believe you'd say that
you're like no it's it's legitimate but
that's that's proven fact and I know the
justice system is not something we can
always trust right in this country but
theoretically like even if the Press
never goes away that's actually this
person's best shot like at least he
would be able to point to something
right now it's just rumor your your
point about the justice system is true
it's not it's imperfect but we as a
society we have to act like we have
faith in it or else that's going to have
significant it's it's significantly
worse to to believe that your justice
system can't be trusted and that's
honestly that's that's probably the
added attitude of a lot more people than
is healthy for society right now yeah
yeah you ever see a Tyson's comments
about that case by the way real quick
where did you where did you hear the
bathroom things I can't find that
anywhere I don't know this is and this
is an issue report this is gonna be like
about a week ago when everyone was first
hearing about the story because again
it's been like since 2020 and it's only
really broke as of like maybe a week ago
I heard uh I think it was like I don't
even remember who was watching but yeah
sorry man what you were saying oh no I
was just saying Mike Tyson's comments
about like the the rape case or whatever
whenever it's brought up he gets really
pissed and he's like no I he's like he
didn't rape her but he said he should
have
he got addicted right he did yeah he did
yeah that's what it's probably what his
thought process is saying that awful
awful line
he's like how old's he know 60 years
he's fine he's like dude I'm done
nobody's gonna do anything he didn't
have sort of law order SVU like he's
clearly bounced back from this
conviction yeah and he'll punch you in
the face and knock your head right off
yeah well don't bring him on the show
and I'll be okay he has that quote where
he says that not enough people are
getting hit or whatever or something
like that yeah it's like well you know I
understand the point he's saying like
it's kind of good people aren't beating
each other up but his point is that uh
actually Taylor Swift has the has the
quote say it uh on the streets it's a
knockout say it in a tweet it's a Kappa
you know she she said it better than
than uh Mike Tyson if you ask me she has
a way with words yeah and then she
throws her phone in the video but she
makes a point like they'll go online
people will say these awful things they
won't say it in real life because
they'll be scared about what the
consequences will be freedom of speech
doesn't mean freedom from consequences
true that's right it's true
yeah but I don't know man I I don't I
don't think it's going to be like a
Resurgence of me too or anything no I
don't know the whole believable women
thing I don't know where that's at I
wonder if they're gonna like have they
have like recordings of him already and
that's the name of their finishing
season seven and they're gonna release
it oh they're gonna put they're gonna
use an AI to make his voice that's the
other thing how bad is that gonna be
remember you guys remember they just cut
the audio from previous there's been
like a bunch of seasons of the show
right they wouldn't do that but you
remember the Joe Rogan voice yep oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay they they they
had a AI analyze Joe Rogan's voice and
they made a thing where you can type in
words and it would say it as Joe Rogan
they'll do that with him I hate
technology that's so creepy yeah you're
gonna be watching him to be like this is
a robot
the the jokes won't have the oomph yeah
for sure because he does the voices and
then does he write the show too or yeah
presumably right I believe so he's like
the spine of this entire thing yeah he's
a show he's Seth MacFarlane yeah exactly
exactly I mean after this like if he
does get proven innocent does he start a
new show oh he's done he's done forever
look man people like him people like
Justin Roiland he's tweeted he tweeted
some anti-woke thing a while ago and
then he deleted it I can't remember
exactly what it was but this is the
point I want to make to everybody
they come for you
um look maybe he's guilty that's if he's
guilty then so be it if he's not guilty
when this all ends and the courts say
Okay case dismissed you ain't get your
job back they're not gonna let you back
in those doors you're done
you should have spoken out and set your
foundation before it was too late now
look I don't blame the guy who seems
mostly apolitical for not realizing the
culture was you know getting to this
point but I'll say to everybody else
because I hear it from people all too
often look I'm trying to keep my head
down and then hopefully like nobody will
come and give me grief it's like oh come
on dude here's what happens you got
arroa houses and they're going door to
door and you think if you turn your
lights off they ignore your house bro
they're going door to door it's it's
going to come to you no matter what you
can speak up now and and Link arms
figuratively with all the people who
agree and tell these people to shut up
or you can duck turn your lights off and
then wait until they come to your house
smash your windows and then burn
everything down yep there and there
there is no there is no way to be like
Oh I'm just not gonna get involved when
it comes to when it comes to
the culture War if someone makes an
accusation you're in whether you like it
or not someone says something about you
you you're in the culture War someone
that that on one side of the culture War
decides they don't like something you
did they make an accusation you're in it
you don't get to opt out there is no
more oh I just stay out of politics that
doesn't happen thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time